Crowd: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
John: Ohh, Hank, it's been an incredibly tense
and overwhelming week in my life, with lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots of interviews,
which I am not good at, but fortunately, I've
usually been with Nat Wolff, who makes everything
in my life better.
And also I got to meet many thousands of Nerdfighters
around the country, more people wanted to
say hello to you, by the way, hold on.
Crowd: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
Other crowd: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
John: Also, I got my photograph taken a lot.
There's this whole commodification of the
self involved in this marketing business that
I don't really understand and haven't processed
yet, but hopefully I'll make a video about
it someday.
In the meantime, all I know is that the fancy
New York premiere of Paper Towns is tonight.
By the way, thanks to everybody on Twitter
and Snapchat who helped me pick out my fancy
premiere suit.
I may need your help later in choosing a tie,
by the way.
The movie comes out on Friday, July 24th,
but on Thursday, which is the day after freaking
tomorrow, there's a special screening at a
bunch of theaters around the US and Canada.
I know some of them are sold out, but some
of them aren't, so hopefully you can still
go to nightonthetowns.com and get tickets,
and then in addition to seeing the movie before
everyone else, you will also see a livestream
with the entire cast and musical performances,
it's going to be really fun.
Also that livestream is gonna be hosted by
our friend, Tyler Oakley, who I've known for
like, eight years and I'm just so proud of
him and so excited that we get to celebrate
this together.
Waaauugh, Hank, you might be able to tell
that I'm a little bit wound up right now.
One of the ways I'm coping with my stress
is by reading reviews of Paper Towns, because
I just really really want people to see it
and find out what they think of it, and I've
just realized that when I earlier said that
people on Thursday would be the first people
to see the movie, I was, in fact, lying, because
the movie is already out in Brazil and Australia
and a couple of other places, and like, lots
of critics have seen it, and fortunately,
the reviews have been great, like, Variety
said that it was better than The Fault in
Our Stars.
Speaking of which, Hank, when I was on tour,
exactly zero interviewers said the title of
The Fault in Our Stars correctly.
They would be like, "Do you feel a lot of
pressure after all the success of No Fault
Under These Stars?"
And I would be like, "Well, I felt more pressure
before I realized that absolutely no one remembers
the title of that movie."
Right, but anyway, I've been obsessively reading
reviews, including reviews from Brazil, but
unfortunately, I do not speak Portuguese,
so I have been reading them via Google Translate
and they are very positive, I--I think.
"Distinguished representative of the school
John Hughes movie, Paper Cities has everything
to be the teen movie of the year.
The result is a fresh and full length humor,
far from the melodrama of blame it star."
Solid work, Google Translate.
Blame it, star!
Anyway, comparisons to John Hughes are always
welcome.
Here's another one, "It is a beautiful film.
The Schreier--" I believe that's director
Jake Schreier, although it could be from The
Hobbit, "--works with actors Wolff and Face--"
Not sure who Face is, maybe Cara?
Maybe Justice? "--is magnificent.
In the reunion of the two, the dialogue is
as accurate and interpretive and sincere Paper
Cities that borders on perfection."
And here's another one, Hank, "Moving away
from the book, literally the film crew approach
the writer in its essence.
It's so exploited rites of passage to adulthood
without the mischievousness of John Hughes,
but with the melancholy of Walt Whitman."
So yeah, no comparison to John Hughes there,
but instead Whitman.
Also welcome.
Somewhere in the grass underneath our boot
soles, Walt Whitman is like, "Yeah, I mean,
I thought the movie was okay, but let's not
get ahead of ourselves."
Anyway, Hank, I hope that you like the movie,
and that Nerdfighteria likes it, and thanks
to everyone who has shared this journey with
me.
One last thing, something I've learned about
movie studios in the last two years is that
they're obsessed with hashtags.
They're obsessed with them because it allows
them to, like, track the success of a campaign,
and I'm sure there will be lots of super official
hashtags around the Paper Towns movie, but
I mostly care about the responses from Nerdfighteria
and people who really care about the story,
so I thought that I would invent a fake hashtag,
and then I can look at that hashtag instead
of like, the official ones.
Don't tell the studio, but there's a link
in the doobly-doo.
Nerdfighters, I hope that you like the movie.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.
p.s.
Hank, I'm so sorry about your VidCon stress,
I hope you might find some comfort in these
images of Pluto, a cold distant former planet
that humans have come together to better understand.